Welcome to 3ABN [music]
Today Bible Q&A. My name is JD Quinn.
I'll be your host. This is a fun time
for me because I get to ask the
questions. We got three of our guests
here, our three ABN family. We have the
Daniel Maronei on the end. Welcome,
Daniel.
>> Thank you so much for having me and it's
always fun to answer these questions.
>> Yeah, it's always fun to be around you.
You're a fun person. And we have John
Denzy. Johnny, it's always good to see
you.
>> Thank you. It's a blessing to be here. I
always enjoy researching these questions
and learning more.
>> Amen. And I got my beautiful wife here,
Shelly. Shel, it's always good to see
you.
>> You're a little prejudice, but thank
you. And thank you so much for sending
in your questions because we enjoy
tackling these and sometimes it takes
quite a long time to prepare these
answers and distill them to three
minutes.
>> What would you say it takes you? Well,
depending on the question, maybe one and
a half to two hours, but some of them,
you know, longer and some of them
shorter.
>> Yeah,
>> Johnny,
>> I would say the same. Some are good 20
30 minutes, but some take longer, an
hour more.
>> Shelly,
>> ditto.
>> And the difficult part, I guess, is with
all the research and everything is to
take it down to get within that three or
four minutes. [laughter]
>> I mean, that would that's something
else. Anyway,
>> uh
we get your questions. We the questions
come in through you and it comes in
three different ways. You can text them
in. The number there is 6182283975.
Perhaps you'd like to email them. That's
Bible QA at 3ABN.tv.
And then if you want to Instagram 3ABN
official and that gets them to us and
then they're distributed accordingly.
Okay, let's uh let's start off by having
a prayer. Father, I just want to thank
you, Lord, for this opportunity to be
able to uh listen to the answers to
these questions. Father, we always have
[music] questions. Father, it's nice to
have answers. So, be with us. Take care
of us. Bless every person that's [music]
watching. Father Jesus, come quickly.
>> Love, we love you, Lord. Give you praise
and glory in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Let's start off asking the
questions. I'm just going to go in the
circle. These going to be three minute
questions, four minute questions. This
is going to be a three-minute question,
I believe. Daniel, does the Bible give
any indication whether the ark of the
covenant was in the most holy place at
the time of Jesus' ministry while here
on earth? And this is from Ben in Idaho.
>> Hey Ben, thank you so much for that
question. You know, I never even thought
about that before. So, that helped me to
figure this out and reading God's word.
So, we don't have any uh mention of the
ark of the covenant being in the most
holy place when Jesus was ministering
here on this earth. And a brief history
of the ark of the covenant starts in
Exodus chapter 25. God in speaking to
Moses tells him to have the children of
Israel bring him an offering. And then
he gives a list of the things that he
wants. Then in verse 8 of chapter 25, it
says, "Let them make me a sanctuary that
I may dwell among them." That was his
invitation. And he was going to be there
with his people. So that ark was
accompanied Israel throughout the 40
years that they wandered in the
wilderness and it was always housed in
an elaborate tent structure that God
directed Moses on how to build. When
David became king, he wanted to build a
temple to house it and God told him that
it would be his son that would have that
privilege. So then the ark of the
covenant was located in this massive
structure that Solomon had built was
called Solomon's temple and which took
about 7 years to complete somewhere
around 950 BC. In 2 Chronicles chapter
25 we read when Solomon had the ark
brought into the most holy place that
the glory of God was so bright that the
priests had to pause their work. And
when Solomon died, the nation split into
two parts. Israel in the north and Judah
in the south. When Israel apostasized,
God allowed Assyria to take over and
rule.
Then Judah forsook God and was taken
captive by Babylon.
You remember Daniel and his three
friends. And Nebuchadnezzar tore down
the walls of Jerusalem, plundered and
burned the temple. And from that point
on, the ark of the covenant is actually
gone from history. We don't have any
more history of it. And uh 70 years
after this captivity, Darius or Das, the
king of Persia, he freed God's people to
rebuild the temple. In the books of Ezra
and Nehemiah, they describe the
struggles that they went through in
building the second temple along with
the city walls.
Ezra 3:12 describes the older generation
who saw the glory of Solomon's temple
weeping when they saw the second temple.
And there was no ark of the covenant in
it. And that was completed around 515
BC. And it continued to stand as it was
until the reign of King Herod.
And then to earn favor with the Jewish
subjects, he renovated it into a thing
of splendor. So this is the temple that
Jesus visited when he was here. And
there's speculation about what happened
to the ark of the covenant, but nothing
definitive. And the thought that makes
most sense to me is that the righteous
people that were still in Jerusalem hid
the ark of the covenant before
Nebuchadnezzar tore it down the temple.
Thank you again, Ben.
>> Amen. Amen. Johnny, your first question.
If the dead know nothing, what is the
purpose of visiting the graves and
bringing flowers? And this is from Trudy
in New York.
>> That is a good question. And you know,
when a loved one dies, people handle it
in different ways. And you have some
that can have some burdens in their
heart, maybe some unresolved thing, and
they feel some kind of comfort by going
to the grave and kind of just letting
letting out what is what's inside. But
the reality is the dead person does not
hear, cannot perceive, has no idea what
is happening. And so there are people
that bring flowers to the graves of
their loved ones. And it's not that the
loved ones are going to smell them or
see them, but they feel good doing this
like honoring them, but there is no
value to the person because the person
I'm sorry I know some people are very
delicate about this.
Some people believe, you know, they want
to they want to honor their loved ones
in some way, keep their grave nice
looking and things like that.
uh in Mexico actually October 31,
November 1 and November 2, they have the
day of the dead and the people really
have some type of I guess you can call
it reverence for their dead if you want
to call it that way. Uh so they bring
their favorite food to the grave, the
favorite food of the person that's dead
to the grave on those days and they have
processions in some of the cities and
decorations and things like that. But
what does the Bible say? Okay. The Bible
says in Ecclesiastes chapter 9 verse 5
and 6, for the living know that they
will die, but the dead know nothing and
they have no more reward for the memory
of them is forgotten. So they have no
idea that you're coming there, that
you're visiting, that you're putting
flowers, whatever it is that you may do.
So what is the point of bringing flowers
for the person that's dead? It has no
value. They are not feeling honored.
They are not rejoicing that you came to
visit them because they have no
knowledge. They have no also it says in
verse 6 Ecclesiastes 9:6 also their
love, their hatred and their envy have
now perished. Never more will they have
a share in anything done under the sun.
So these loved ones are not really
understanding what you're doing. And so
for example uh let's go to Job chapter
14. In Job chapter 14, you can see that
it is he's talking about uh there it's
talking there about those that die. It
says uh verse 10, but man dies and is
laid away. Indeed, he breathes his last
and where is he? As water disappears
from the sea and a river becomes parched
and dries up, so man lies down and does
not rise till the heavens are no more.
They will not awake nor be aroused from
their sleep. The Bible calls death a
sleep. And there's a first resurrection
and a second resurrection divided by
1,000 years. Look at this verse in Job
14:21. His sons come to honor and he
does not know it. They are brought low
and he does not perceive it. So there is
nothing of benefit to the person that
has passed away. So if you want to honor
your loved ones, honor them while they
are alive. Amen.
>> Amen. Good answer.
>> Shelley, your first question. Can you
please explain John 14:12?
Are miracles a way of getting spiritual
results? At the end of Jesus' life,
everyone ran away and left him even
though he did so many miracles. And this
is from Anthony in Canada.
>> Anthony, let's read John 14:12. Jesus
said,"Most assuredly I say to you, he
who believes in me, the works that I do,
he will do also, and greater works than
these he will do because I go to my
father." I am going to suggest the
greater works are in extent
um the preaching of the gospel was to go
to all the world. And it's the spiritual
miracle of seeing people being born
again as they receive the truth. It's
not greater works in power as in
physical miracles. Let me tell you why.
Miracles are an act of mercy. They're
signs of God's presence that reveal us
power and compassion. They may open the
door, but they're not a shortcut to
spiritual maturity. They never were
God's primary method for producing
lasting spiritual change.
the one of the early miracles, the
parting of the Red Sea. The Israelites
in Exodus 14, they look upon the dead
Egyptians that were covered when the sea
closed again. They marvel at God's
demonstration of power. They feared the
Lord. They feared Moses. And they sang
in Exodus 15:2. These are the
Israelites. Oh, the Lord is my strength
and my song. He's become my salvation.
He's my God. I will praise him, my
father's God, and I will exalt him. And
guess what? Three days later, they were
murmuring. They were complaining. They
were doubting. There was no lasting
impact the miracle of parting the Red
Sea had on their attitude. Later they
witnessed water from the the mana, the
water from the rock, the presence,
physical presence in the pillar of fire
and the cloud
of God. And yet their unbelief
persisted. Miracles amazed them, but it
did not anchor their hearts in faith.
Jesus raised the the healed the sick,
raised the dead and fed the multitudes
with love. The disciples witnessed it,
but they abandoned him at the cross.
Matthew 26:56 said, "All the disciples
[snorts]
forsook him and fled." So witnessing
miracles does not guarantee
spiritual loyalty. And scripture is
clear that miracles alone do not create
enduring faith. In fact, Jesus said in
Matthew 16:4, "A wicked and adulterous
generation seek after a sign." So signs
can attract, but it's truth received in
the heart that transforms lives. Romans
10:17 says, "Faith comes by hearing, not
by seeing, but by hearing, and hearing
by the word." In Acts two, we see at
Pentecost that all the people were
changed not because of signs alone, but
because their hearts were convicted by
truth. So quickly, the lasting spiritual
miracles, spiritual results come through
surrender, obedience, motivated by love,
and a daily walk with Christ, guided by
his word, and empowered by the Holy
Spirit.
>> Good answer. Good answer, Shelley.
Daniel, your second question. I want to
know if there's any difference in saying
Jesus Christ or Christ Jesus. To me, it
seems to mean more than what you say in
g in Christ Jesus. The Bible seems to
indicate more reverence in saying it
that way. Also, which is better or does
it even matter? And this is from Sue in
New Mexico.
Sue, thank you for that insightful
question.
To start with, let's see how Jesus got
his name. In Matthew 1:21, it says that
the angel as he was talking to Joseph,
remember Joseph was want put away Mary
because she was already pregnant.
And so this angel is talking to Joseph
and she shall bring forth a son and thou
shalt call his name Jesus for he shall
save his people from their sins. This is
the Greek rendition of Josh Joshua
meaning uh Jehovah saves.
So while the counts vary with different
translations,
Jesus Christ appears significantly more
often than Christ Jesus where the Jesus
is the his name and then Christ is his
title. Um, so I think you're correct,
Sue, as far as when you start with
Christ and then you say Jesus because
you're, it seems to be more respectful.
And Paul actually favors that Christ
Jesus. And he uses it about 80 to 100
times stressing Jesus's exalted office,
his glory, and his divine identity as
the anointed one or the Messiah.
While the gospels and the book of acts
commonly use Jesus Christ
um between 140 to 200 times focusing on
Jesus as a historical person,
the Messiah.
So when people speak of the like the
president of the United States, they
usually start with president then they
give his name like President Abraham
Lincoln.
But you also hear it the other way,
giving the first and last name and then
saying president of the United States.
So there really isn't any correct or
incorrect order, but it depends on what
you're emphasizing.
You know, the person's office or the
person themselves. And it just depends.
So by the way, the word Christ by itself
appears over 500 times. and then Jesus
by itself a thousand times. So again,
Sue, thank you so much for the question
and blessing.
Amen. That's interesting right there.
John
Johnny, I am a Seventh Day Adventist.
Recently, a friend of mine from a
different denomination asked me to join
them for Bible study. In the study, the
speaker mentioned Colossians 1:es
21- 23. and stated that after Jesus paid
the price for our sins, he no longer
views us as sinners but as righteous.
They also mentioned that our separation
from God is because of our thoughts. I
responded that I believe Paul was
referring to our thoughts as our minds
meaning of Colossians 1:21-23.
And this is from Mahalia.
Well, thank you Maha for the question
and we'll try to get through as much as
we can. Uh the Bible makes a difference
in from the beginning to the end that
there are the righteous and there are
the wicked. Uh you can see this all the
way in for example in Genesis chapter 18
and uh verse 23 when Abraham is talking
uh with the Lord and it says in Genesis
18:23 and Abraham came near and said
would you also destroy the righteous
with the wicked so you see here that a
difference is being made of the
righteous and the wicked and in the
Bible we have the script scriptures
Romans 3 23 and onward. It says, "For
all have sinned and fall short of the
glory of God, being justified freely by
his grace through the redemption that is
in Christ Jesus, whom God has set forth
as the as a propitiation by his blood
through faith to demonstrate his
righteousness because in his
forbearance, God had passed over the
sins that were previously committed to
demonstrate the present at the present
time his righteousness." And now notice
that he might be just and the justifier
of the one who has faith in Jesus. So
having faith in Jesus then you can be
justified and this is made free to
everyone. In first Peter 4:1 18 it says,
"And if the righteous scarcely be saved,
where shall the ungodly and the sinner
appear?" A difference is being made as
the righteous and the sinners. Proverbs
chapter 1 verse 10. My son, if sinners
entice thee, consent thou not. Again, a
difference is being made here. Uh, evil
pursue sinners,
but to the righteous good shall be.
Proverbs 13:21.
Let night let not thine heart envy
sinners, but be thou in the fear of the
Lord all the day long. So a difference
is being made and this was based on the
sacrifice that was coming Jesus Christ.
So when Jesus Christ comes
um then the plan of salvation is assured
and all of the people that believe
before Jesus died on the cross it was
based on the promise of the coming
savior Jesus Christ. the promise that
was started in Genesis 3:15 that the the
seed of the woman that would be Christ
would come and give that death blow on
the head of the serpent which is the
devil. Uh in Colossians chapter one that
you mentioned uh beginning in verse one,
Paul an apostle of Jesus Christ by the
will of God and Timothy our brother.
Notice it says to the saints and
faithful brethren in Christ who are in
Colasse. Grace to you and peace from God
our father and the Lord Jesus Christ. In
the New Testament you have the term the
saints uh which are the righteous God's
followers. This is what is uh being
brought out here in Colossians chapter
1. Uh that's Colossians chapter 1 verse
one and two. Now we jump to Colossians 1
21-23 that you mentioned. And you who
were once alienated and enemies in your
mind by wicked works yet now he has
reconciled.
Why? Because the death of Christ brings
reconciliation. H but we have to
exercise faith in that Christ in that
sacrifice he made. And it says in the
body of his flesh through death to
present you holy and blameless and above
reproach in his sight. If indeed notice
you continue in the faith, we must
continue in the faith grounded and
steadfast and are not moved away from
the hope of the gospel which you heard
which was preached to every creature
under heaven of which I Paul became a
minister. So we must remain grounded in
the faith. We must uh remain uh
steadfast and be not moved away from the
gospel. So yes, u God's people are
called righteous and the wicked that are
not following the Lord, they are called
sinners.
>> Amen. Good. That's very good, Johnny.
>> Very good.
>> Shelley, your second question.
>> If I eat meals that are prepared by
others during the Sabbath hours, am I
violating the Sabbath Sabbath day laws
and thereby sinning willfully against
God? And this is from Josh. Josh, your
question reflects a heart's your heart's
desire to honor God, and that matters
greatly to him. I just want to point out
that the Sabbath was created by God as a
gift to mankind. It's about
relationship.
It's about rest and delight in God. Mark
2:27-28,
Jesus said, "The Sabbath was made for
man, not man for the Sabbath. Therefore,
the Lord, the son of man, is also Lord
of the Sabbath.
>> So, the point I'm making is Jesus
consistently resisted turning the
Sabbath into an observance of rigid
rules. The Sabbath was not to be a
burden of fear and guilt, but it was
created to be a blessing. God values
reverence, love, and peace over rigid
rulekeeping. In Isaiah 58:13-14,
God says we are to call the Sabbath a
delight and we are to find our delight
in his avoid secular activity so that we
can find delight in his presence. The
Sabbath was created to lead us into a
deeper trust, a deeper rest and joy in
the Lord. Now, I want to lay down a
couple of principles and get to your
question. Nehemiah 13:15-22
clearly tells us, and [snorts] there's
many other places in the Bible, there
should be no buying and selling on the
Sabbath. We're to honor the spirit of
the Sabbath by keeping it distinct from
commerce. Exodus 16 and ex that chapter
16 in Exodus 28-11
when we're talking about Sabbath
preparation.
It emphasizes avoiding ordinary labor
and business and from causing others to
engage in ordinary labor on our behalf.
And that's so the day can be set apart
as a day of worship, rest, and servant.
Sabbath observance is shaped by love for
God, sanctity for his holy day, and love
for other people. not fear. We prepare
meals ahead of time. This is not about
legalism or trying to earn God's favor,
but it is to remove distractions and
burdens from that day so we can enjoy
oursel. The key issue is intent, the
spirit. It's not mere circumstance. So,
here's what I'll say. If you are a guest
at someone's home and graciously
receiving hospitality is not a sin. That
principle's laid down in Luke 10:7. If
food is shared as part of fellowship or
ministry or necessity, this aligns with
the Sabbath promise of blessing. Eating
in restaurants is discouraged because
that involves buying or selling. paid
labor that scripture associates with
ordinary work. However, I'm going to add
this. Jesus taught in Matthew 12 11-12
that acts of necessity and mercy are
always appropriate on the Sabbath. And
there are times, there are situations
where you may be traveling and don't
even intend to travel on the on Sabbath
and you're stuck in an airport and
travel delays and emergencies or illness
or caring for others may make restaurant
food the only available option. And in
such cases, God does not condemn a
sincere heart who's seeking to honor him
under difficult circumstances. God looks
at the heart, at the motive, at the
spirit. Jesus said in Matthew 12:78, "If
you'd known what this means, I desire
mercy, not sacrifice, you would have not
condemned the guiltless." So the guiding
question isn't did I break a rule, but
does this choice honor the spirit of
Sabbath observance?
>> Wonderful.
I just want to take just a couple of
seconds here and just remind you of how
to contact us here at 3ABN. You can text
in at 6182283975.
Perhaps you want to email. It's bible
3ABN.tv.
And there's people that like Instagram.
That's 3ABN
official.
>> Okay, Daniel, let's go to number three
question.
>> All right.
Can you please explain Daniel 6:10?
Daniel Daniel 6:10. Why does Daniel face
towards Jerusalem when he prays? Does it
mean that there are specific directions
to face when we pray? And this is from
Monica.
>> Monica, great question. It's a two-part
question there, it looks like. So, I'm
going to address that first part. Why
did Daniel pray toward Jerusalem there?
Well, you know, the city of Jerusalem
was where Solomon's temple was located.
And here's Solomon's dedicatory prayer,
and it goes along with being a captive
in a foreign land. Um, it's in First
Kings 8:48.
And so return unto thee with all their
heart. Talking about those captives, you
know, they must have been uh bad. And so
then they were taken captive somewhere.
and so return unto thee with all their
heart and with all their soul in the
land of their enemies which led them
away captive and then pray unto thee
toward their land. So like Babylon was
east of u Israel so anyway he'd be
praying toward the west there toward
their land which thou gavest unto their
father the city which thou hast chosen
the house which I have built. So this is
Solomon in his prayer and so he's
talking about the temple there. So this
is most likely why Daniel prayed toward
Jerusalem where the temple was located
and God's presence was manifested with a
shakina of glory over the mercy seat in
the most holy place. As far as the
second part of your question there
regarding what we need to do today, you
know, I don't know of any scripture that
tells as we uh the direction, but we
need to pray a certain direction.
But I would say that whatever you can do
in your prayer experience to make it
more of a living experience rather than
just a ceremony or a a dead habit or
whatever mechanical meaningless. So I'm
pretty sure that when Daniel was praying
there in the direction of Jerusalem in
his mind's eye, he could see the temple.
He could imagine in his mind's eye God's
presence there.
And so when we're communicating with
God, the creator of the whole universe,
we want to be able to do what what we
can realize whom we're worshiping and
whom we're addressing that would
facilitate an experience rather than
just this dead formality. So I usually
have my eyes closed. By the way, I
thinking of Jesus when he blessed that
bread when he was feeding the 5000. You
know, he looked up, it said, and then he
blessed the bread. it. So, I usually
have my eyes closed while I'm holding my
head up as if I'm looking toward heaven
and imagine God listening to me.
>> And on a clear morning when I can see
the stars, I've kept my eyes open. And
first, you know, I'm looking out.
Usually, I'm looking out in the west
window. It's a nice view for us. And
when it's clear, I can see the stars and
I just kind of imagine, you know, the
awesomeness of God and his creation
before I close my eyes just to get
myself in a in a more of a mood, I'll
say recognizing whom God is, the creator
of everything. Anyway, so I would that's
my answer to that question. So,
>> Amen. Amen.
>> Johnny, your third question. The word of
God says not to eat unclean meat, but
some meat is considered clean like fish.
If we eat fish that eat the shrimp and
other unclean things in the water, how
can we still eat clean fish and God be
okay with it?
>> That's a very interesting question. Uh I
when in doubt, don't do it. Some people
[laughter] say,
you know, it's very interesting. you put
together a scenario underwater that we
don't know what happens under there
>> and uh if you are concerned then it's
best not to eat it but it's true that
some fish eat shrimp but which ones
those are I really don't know I don't
have that information but yes in
Leviticus 11 there is a list and
description of animals that are
considered unclean which means unfit to
eat they're not as healthy as eating
clean animals uh also you can find this
in the book of Deuteronomy chapter 14.
Uh somewhat the same information. Uh by
the way, the birds in the birds section
is they're mentioned by name, not by
characteristics. Uh Leviticus chapter
11, I'm just going to read verses 9, 10,
and 11. Uh these you may eat of all that
are in the water. Whatever in the water
has fins and scales, whether in the seas
or in the rivers that you that you may
eat. But all in the seas or in the
rivers that do not have fins and scales,
all that move in the water, or any
living thing which is in the water, they
are an abomination to you. They shall be
an abomination to you. You shall not eat
their flesh, but you shall regard their
carcasses as an abomination. Whatever in
the water does not have fins or scales,
that shall be an abomination to you. So
yes, the shrimp would be included in
that class. That should not be eaten.
And if you want to know what these
little creatures eat, I went to the
internet to find out. Shrimp are
omnivorous scavengers eating mostly
organic debris, algae, and bofilm, but
also small organisms like plankton,
worms, and decaying plants, acting as
nature's clean up crew by consuming dead
stuff, uh, decorus, it says, and even
parasites of larger fish. Their diet
varies by species from filter feeding
brine shrimp to bottom sifting varieties
and include plants, small invertebrates,
and fish. Now, notice that I read that
these are nature's cleanup crew. Really,
the unclean animals are God's cleanup
crew. What do they eat? Dead things or
dying things and decaying things. So
when you think of pork, when you think
of or swine, however you want to call
it, and these uh fish and that do not
have scales, they are God's cleanup
crew. More susceptible to having
diseases and bacteria and parasites in
them that eating them would place you in
greater risk of getting sick. And so we
really need to evaluate these things.
But the question is, can we eat clean
animals? Yes, the Bible has not given us
a do not eat clean animals anywhere in
the Bible. So if you want to eat clean
animals, you can. But be very careful to
eat that which is best because your body
is a temple of the Holy Spirit.
>> Amen.
>> Shelly, your third question.
What if we love the Lord and obey his
commandments, but we don't want to live
forever?
Is that wrong? I was thinking maybe
that's why we still have to eat from the
tree of life when we go to heaven. So if
we don't want to live any longer but
just want to rest, we can do so.
>> I wish I had your name and I sure hope
you're watching. I admire your love
relationship with the Lord and and that
your obedience is motivated by love, not
not that you're trying to escape death
or even seeking an endless life. In John
14:15, Jesus said, "If you love me, keep
my commandments." So that is the
foundation. Obedience motivated by love
of a covenant relationship. I have to
say this, your question reflects a heart
that is weary and burdened by what life
has dealt you, worn out, if you will.
And I want to say that your perspective
of eternal life when you think of it,
it's unimaginable and it sounds
exhausting. Although I want to be
sensitive, very sensitive to this
answer. I'm going to speak fast because
I have a lot to say. God has
compassionate understanding for what
you're going through and he wants to
reassure you. What feels exhausting now
is what's shaped by sin and pain and
loss and fatigue. But the everlasting
life of the redeemed will share no
comparison. Revelation 21:4 says, "God
will wipe away every tear from their
eyes. No more death, sorrow, crying,
tears. There shall be no more pain. For
the former things have passed away." So
if you think about that, this is the
everlasting life is the end of fear.
It's the end of pressure and weariness
and fatigue. Isaiah 65:17
says, "The former things will not be
remembered or come to mind." Eternal
life is a gift of God's grace. It's not
a burden. James 4:17 says he's the giver
of every good and perfect gift. So
eternal life is presented not just as
endless existence, but as endless joy in
God's presence.
Psalm 16:11 says, "In your presence is
fullness of joy at your right hand are
pleasures forever more." So joy, peace,
purpose, love in the new earth will
awaken in us a desire to live forever.
And not out of obligation, but out of
delight. When sin, pain, and exhaustion
are gone, the joy of life with God will
be so complete. That living forever will
be uh feel just natural. It'll feel
welcome and deeply satisfying. It's not
just going to be endured, but embraced.
First Corinthians 2:9 says, "Eye has not
seen nor heard the things which God has
prepared for those who love him." So
eternal life is described
not as endless striving but as entering
God's rest. Hebrews 4:9 and 10 says
there remains therefore a rest for the
people of God for he who has entered his
rest has himself also ceased from his
works as God did from his. So what this
passage does is it's connecting
salvation, eternal life and rest, not as
inactivity,
but as abiding peace and completion and
security in God. It echoes the Sabbath
rest, right, that we keep now that
points forward to the final rest of the
redeemed in eternity. Now, 1 Corinthians
15:52
tells us at the last trumpet when Jesus
returns, we will be changed in the
twinkling of the eye. It says that this
corruptible will put on incorruption.
Our mortality will put on immortality.
And it is true. Revelation 2:7 says, "To
the one who's victorious, I'll give the
right to eat from the tree of life." now
which is in the paradise of God.
Scripture does not state though that
there's a requirement to eat from the
tree of life for the continued
immortality that we put on at the
resurrection. It's part of the new life,
the new creation. It symbolizes the
lifegiving power of God and restoration
of what was lost in Eden. We'll live in
God's presence forever more. And what
that tree of life I think does is it
proves to us that living with God and in
uh remaining this immortality is
relational and dependent on communion
with him. So please take these Bible
promises to heart and know that you have
something to look forward to.
>> Amen.
>> Very good. Very compassionate. Very
compassionate.
>> Daniel, your fourth question. As a
student, I have been battling with the
urge to study on the Sabbath. During the
week, I am busy with classes, work, and
much more. Saturday and Sunday are my
only free days. Would it be a sin if I
studied school work on the Sabbath and
caught up on my assignments?
That's a great question. You know,
actually, I had those same temptations
when I was taking nursing over 50 years
ago.
But I felt peace when I made the
decision to do the best I could without
studying on the Sabbath. And I told the
Lord, "Well, I'm yours. If you want me
to pass, then I will. If not, you've got
something else for me to do."
And then more recently, I finished my
masters in pastoral ministry without
studying on the Sabbath. And I believe
God blesses you with extra understanding
when you put him first.
>> Amen. It's kind of like tithe, you know,
you say, "Man, I don't have enough money
to pay tithe." But when you return that,
then God blesses you. It's very similar.
Um, well, you know how much reading
there is in college there. And, um, even
more in the graduate level, there's a
lot of, you know, seems like they've got
nothing better to do than assign you a
bunch of stuff to read. And, um, and I'm
not a fast reader. In fact, to be
honest, I'm a slow reader when it comes
to comprehension.
So, one of my fellow students told me
about the Apple iPhone, the feature that
it reads to you out loud. So, um I got
most of my textbooks on uh the Kindle
version of the book and then I would
turn up the speed, you know, kind of
like I don't know if anybody remembers
the chipmunks, you know, they speed the
thing and just talking really fast and
so I would actually get it as high as it
could go. was twice as fast and you you
just [laughter] so but I'm just
listening to I've got my earphones on
and I'm doing whatever I needed to do to
get done and so I'm hearing all that and
I believe that it was really neat that
the Lord gave me the comprehension to
stay ahead of the rattling off there was
amazing and to be able to comprehend
that. So I was quote reading at the same
time that I was getting this other work
done that I needed to get done and I
passed. Praise the Lord.
>> Amen. Same with nursing. In fact, the
nursing is pretty interesting. You know,
I took my boards in California and it's
they used to say, I don't know if that's
still the case or not, really hard
boards, state board exam, but passed it
on the first time. They give you five
tries. It was so hard, but anyway,
praise the Lord, I passed on the first
try. Um, here's a scripture for us in
Isaiah 58:13 and 14. It says, "If thou
turn away thy foot from the Sabbath,"
not trampling on it, you know, turning
away your foot from doing thy pleasure
on my holy day, not that it's
pleasurable maybe to study, but uh your
own way, says, "And call the Sabbath a
delight, the holy of the Lord honorable,
and shalt honor him, not doing thine own
ways, nor finding thine own pleasure,
nor speaking thine own words, then shalt
thou delight thyself in the Lord, and I
will cause thee to ride upon upon the
high places of the earth, and feed thee
with the heritage of Jacob thy father.
For the mouth of the Lord hath spoken.
Praise the Lord. He's good. He'll take
care of you.
>> Amen. I don't know if this is a true
statement or not, but I don't imagine
chipmunks has been ever mentioned on
Bible Q&A. [laughter]
Maybe there's
>> nobody nobody knows what they're talking
about there. You guys do because you
were laughing.
>> Oh,
Johnny number four. I'm interested in a
topic I've been hearing about recently.
The Calaldanss. Who are they? I have
been ve I have seen various explanations
from different churches, but they don't
make any sense. Who are the Calaldanss?
And this is from Roy.
>> Well, thank you, Roy. I don't know what
you have heard, and I'm not sure if
you're going to hear the same thing
again. It is my hope and prayer that
this will help you get started in Who
Are the Calaldanss? I first turn to
Genesis 11:31.
And it says, "And Terara took Abram his
son, and Lot, the son of Haron, his
son's son, and Sarai his
daughter-in-law, his son, Abram<unk>'s
wife, and they went forth with them from
of the Caldes to go into the land of
Canaan, and they came into Heron, unto
Heron, and dwelt there." So it says of
the Caldes. So these Calaldanss came
from uh a land from long ago. Well, who
were these people? Uh, they are they
were actually pagans. Uh, for this I
turn to Joshua 24 verse two. This gives
evidence that they were pagans because
there's mention of the people that were
worshiping other gods that are not
really gods. And it says in Joshua 24:2,
"And Joshua said unto all the people,
thus sayith the Lord God of Israel, your
fathers dwelt on the other side of the
[snorts] flood in old time, even Terara,
the father of Abraham and the father of
Nore, and they served other gods."
>> So here's mentioning the father of
Abraham, and they served other gods. So
these people were pagans. In Job 1:1 17,
it gives you something about the nature
of these people. It says, "While he was
still speaking, remember that Job uh I'm
going to stop there a moment. Uh Job was
attacked by the devil and this is one of
the attacks that Job received when the
devil moved upon the Calaldanss. Notice
Job 1:17. While he was still speaking,
another also came and said, "The
Calaldanss formed three bands, raided
the camels, and took them away. Yes. And
killed the servants with the edge of the
sword, and I alone have escaped to tell
you." So who are these Calaldans? They
were not nice people in those days. Uh
notice how it says in Habach, something
about them. Notice
it says beginning in verse 6, Habach 1
16 and onward, for indeed I am raising
up the Calaldanss, a bitter and hasty
nation which marches through the breath
of the earth to possess dwelling places
that are not theirs. So who are these
people? These are mercenaries. They want
to take over people. They want to take
over what people owned. They are
terrible and dreadful. Their judgment
and their dignity proceed from
themselves. Their horses are also
swifter than leopards and more fierce
than evening wolves. Their chargers
charge ahead. Their cavalry comes from
afar. They fly as the eagle that hastens
to eat. They all come for violence. They
were a violent people. Their faces are
like the east wind. They gather captives
like the sand. They scoff at kings and
princes are scorned by them. They deride
every stronghold for they heap up earn
mounds and seize it. Then his mind
change changes and he transgresses. He
commits offense ascribing the power to
his god. So these were fierce terrible
people that like to just invade other
places and take over whatever they had.
And they were warlike people. They were
people they considered a predatory race.
As you continue reading, you will notice
that the Babylonians and the calaldans
seem to be merged together. And one
commentator says that when the
Calaldanss and the Babylonians come
together, the history of the Babylonians
is the same as the history of the
Calaldanss. This is as much as I can
share for the time we have.
>> Very good. Good stuff there.
Shelley, your fourth question. Did
Lucifer know Jesus only as the angel
Michael while in heaven causing his
jealousy? Why was Lucifer the highest
ranked angel in heaven and not Michael?
>> I'm going to give you a quick word study
here. In the Hebrew, the word Messiah
means the anointed one. In the Greek,
the same for the anointed one.
>> Instead of Messiah, it is Christ means
the anointed one. So both of those as
Daniel said earlier are titles. Same
referring to the same the anointed one.
It's referring to the second person of
the godhead who stepped out of heaven to
become the son of man and the covenant
son of God.
The Messiah Christ came from heaven and
into the person of Mary then became the
person of Jesus. That's when he came
into existence at the incarnation when
God took on human flesh. So when he
became the covenant son of God,
this was the Messiah Christ through whom
we would have access to grace and
righteousness by faith. But Christ as
Messiah always eternally existed with
the father. John 1 and 1 through3. In
the beginning was the word. The word was
with God and the word was God and all
things were made through him. Nothing
was made without him. All things were
made with him. And John 1:14 says the
word became flesh.
And this God came became flesh and dwelt
among us and we beheld his glory. So the
Messiah Christ bears the title Michael
the Archangel. God has a number of
titles. Yahweh, El Shadai, Adoni. Uh
there's many titles, but Michael the
Archangel in certain contexts like Jan
Daniel 10:3, Jude 9, First Thessalonians
4:16.
Now, here's another little word study.
The word angel which in the Hebrew is
malach and in the Greek angelos.
Both words Hebrew and Greek can refer to
a man, a prophet, an anointed
I mean a created cherub that we that's
normally what we're thinking of. But the
word angel in both languages means
messenger.
So, Michael the Archangel,
archangel means commander of all angels.
The Messiah himself is the commander of
the heavenly host. And we find that in
Joshua 5:13-15.
Christ's
authority was inherent. It was not
assigned. He was not ranked among the
angels. He was their creator, their
leader. Lucifer was created as the most
exalted of angels in beauty and wisdom
and his capacity to reflect the divine
glory. And we find in Ezekiel 28:14 and
15, God is speaking to him and he says,
"You are the anointed cherub who covers.
You were perfect in your ways from the
day you were created." So Lucifer had a
high position of honor near God's
throne. He was entrusted with great
responsibility.
But Ezekiel 28:17 says, "Your heart was
lifted up because of your be your
beauty." So Lucifer, what happened? He
sought a position that was never made
available to a created being. We find
this in Isaiah 14:14 where Lucifer's
pride he is saying I will ascend above
the heights of the clouds. I will be
like the most high. So Lucifer's fall
came from pride, not misunderstanding.
Rebellion arose when the jealousy and
resentment of he had [clears throat] for
Christ's unique authority. There was no
confusion about Christ's nature. He knew
the Messiah Christ was God. Scripture
shows that he knew exactly who the
Messiah was, that he was the eternal God
himself, the heavenly commander, Michael
the Archangel, and he wanted equality
with him and independence from him. So
Lucifer chose to rebel not in confusion,
not in a dispute over titles or
identity, but in willful pride and
selfexaltation
against God. He willfully rejected God's
government of love.
>> Wow, that was deep stuff. Thank you,
Shelley.
>> Now, let's take a short break. We'll be
right back and pick up some loose ends.
Okay.
If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
[music]
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on [music] those texts that seem
difficult to understand. To have your
questions answered on a future program,
just email them [music] to us at
bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bible [music] qa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-2283975.
[music]
That's 618-228-3975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live [music] and then watch through
Bible Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Welcome back. Welcome back each one of
you. Do any of you have something that
you might have not had time to talk
about? Well, you know, I was thinking
about that prayer experience when we're
praying to God. Knowing him is the key.
Getting to know God. You know, that's
one of the things Jesus said, "I never
knew you and you for depart from me."
So, we want to know God and allow God to
know us. So, we'll have that
relationship through our prayer time.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Amen. I want to share Psalm 119
105. Your word is a lamp to my feet and
a light to my path. And in these
difficult times that we live in, as we
see things going on all around us that
tell us that the prophecies are being
fulfilled, I want to encourage you to
make God's word your light. Let it light
your path and continue trusting in the
Lord with all your heart.
>> Amen. And I just want to say to the
brother or sister who wrote in about
their questions about even desiring
eternal life. Um many people are weary
and you know we cannot imagine what God
has planned for us. But look up these
scriptures that we discussed and really
let those soak in because you will I
know that when we get to heaven and
we're living with God face to face, the
joy that we find in his presence and we
will be developing. Eternity is going to
be wonderful.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. First, I just want to thank you
for all three of you. Lots of energy
went into this and I want to thank each
one of you for choosing to spend this
time with us.
Never forget that Jesus loves you. We
love you and thank you for all that you
do for us. And we're here for you.
>> Bless
>> [music]
>> Good morning.